that is one big pile of shit norm of the
north is an animated film about a polar
bear named norm voiced by veteran actor
Rob Schneider who enjoys twerking while
listening to his iPod in the Arctic and
he decides to travel to New York City to
stop an evil land developer from putting
houses in the Arctic according to box
office mojo calm this movie was released
in 2411 theaters today across the United
States of America and I saw it look you
probably clicked on this review knowing
I hate it you've expected me to tell you
how terrible it is how about I just let
the children in my theater speak for
themselves during the last 30 minutes of
this movie the young girl sitting behind
me who I would estimate was probably
about four years old was so antsy and so
bored that she just got up in her seat
and started walking around the metal bar
and like holding it and doing little
moves and stuff because she was just so
bored out of her mind a kid ahead of me
towards the end of the movie it fades
out for a second and I hear this kid go
is it over and then it fades back into
more movie and I hear him go oh man so
if the kids in my theater hated the
experience of watching this movie
just please visually imagine just please
really imagine that I am a person I'm a
27 year old man and I went to this movie
and I sat there and I watched it it took
every single ounce of willpower within
me to not leave my god
this is and I've thought about this I've
thought hard about this over the past
few hours I think this is the worst
animated movie I have ever seen in a
theatre there is so much that is wrong
about this movie for one it looks as if
it belongs on Nickelodeon in 1998 and
sure enough I look in the IMDB trivia
page and it says this was originally
going to be a straight to DVD movie but
they decided at the last minute I guess
to just put it in theaters so why the
hell not
can you just not normally North is like
an animated film that you scroll past on
Netflix and go oh no the director of
this movie is obsessed with cross
dissolves every single scene ends with a
cross dissolve like every single one of
them cross dissolves over and over again
the animation is so incredibly subpar
it's not even really straight to DVD
it's like more straight to TV
can I please remind you that the star of
this movie is Rob Schneider the
resolution even was terrible and I saw
this movie in a very new theater just
barely a year old this theater is by my
house distance shots where people were
farther away you couldn't even see much
Definition animated into their faces it
is atrocious
it's inexcusably lazy there's an excuse
that gets easily thrown around oh it's
just a kids movie and now you're being
too harsh on it this movies made for
children as I already said the kids in
my theater wanted to leave anime films
from Japan like Studio Ghibli's
productions or Pixar's productions or
DreamWorks these people have shown us
that kids can enjoy films that are
really good and smart and mature and
have depth and have layers this film is
only suitable for children who perhaps
can't even speak the English language
yet the only thing this movie could
possibly do is maybe entertain an infant
that's it it's a terribly unfunny movie
with awful characters and equally awful
animation the story barely even makes
any sense things happen that don't make
sense like early on in the movie we see
a little girl just run up to a polar
bear and the parents aren't even
concerned about it they don't even they
don't even show the parents being
concerned they don't even animate the
parents going oh gosh no that the kids
is the little girl just runs up to a
polar bear they don't even take the time
to animate concerned parents Oh God look
if you want to see an animated film
that's 86 minutes long I believe filled
with scenes of a twerking bear with
subpar animation voiced by Rob Schneider
in which they try to string a story in a
message about development and you have
to save the environment and everything
in there in some way then go right ahead
but please just keep in mind that your
IQ points are at stake here guys you
need those they're important you need
them to think and need them to operate
in everyday
life and if you go to see Norma the
North like I did you will walk out of
the theater slightly dumber I guarantee
it because I drove home from this movie
in almost other shock I was just like
this this happened I what why'd I do
this oh what's that over there it was
that a what was that I honestly had to
sit down and process this movie for many
hours before I even felt capable of
discussing just how truly horrible norm
of the north is if you haven't guessed
I'm going to give this film and f I love
what I do I know that it's not
physically strenuous like some jobs are
but holy shit
today was work on a positive note on a
happy note on oh my gosh I get to
finally breathe note I am still running
my campaign with audible.com slash Chris
if you guys go to that website
audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free 30-day trial which includes a free
audio book of your choice I love this
website it has helped a lot of my
viewers and I've loved hearing that you
guys have enjoyed reading these books
for free they have so much stuff on
there Stephen King stuff Star Wars stuff
they have so many things a lot of people
have actually messaged me saying that
they needed a book for school and
because of this free audio book offer
and free 30-day trial they were able to
obtain that so please check out
audible.com slash Chris these guys have
been amazing sponsoring my videos for I
think a couple years now thank you so
much audible and thank you to you guys
definitely check out audible.com slash
Chris for that free 30-day trial and
free audio book you guys are the best
please don't see norm of the north if
you can avoid it it would be very good
for you to not see it if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man iced